[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
good luck yeah so far hundreds of
challengers no winners we don't make
mistakes they keep coming up yep
well tonight a fan named Joel from
Chicago believes he has caught a mistake
he says it happened during a recent
monologue when I made a joke about
insulin hey Conan Joel here from the
Chicago area last week you made it a
joke about Pfizer the pharmaceutical
company coming out with cinnamon
flavored insulin for the holidays the
makers of Pringles are coming out with a
white chocolate peppermint flavored
potato chip in a in a related story
Pfizer is coming out with cinnamon
flavored insulin so as a pharmacy
student I couldn't let this go because I
know insulin is a protein and would get
broken down if you take it orally so
it's only available via subcutaneous
injection so you're wrong
well before we get started
congratulations I see you got the new
Silence of the Lambs home decorating kit
you know energy said Chicago area like
he's anticipating capture where yeah
well anyway Joel I'm sure you're an
excellent pharmacy student but you are
dead wrong insulin can be taken orally
and to prove it take a look at this ad
from our latest sponsor the new insulin
juice box an all-natural blend of 9%
cane sugar and 10% cinnamon insulin it's
the only juice drink that causes and
treats diabetes
not available Arizona California
Connecticut Delaware Oh Idaho Illinois
Iowa Kansas Kentucky may know
Massachusetts Michigan Minnesota
Missouri Montana Nebraska Nevada
production to do next when we work with
Carolina medico to Ohio Bobo important
the making broad South Carolina South
Dakota you talk about their discontent
[Applause]
lucky Guam yeah lucky Guam so the
challenge still stands if you think
you've spotted an error on our show
reported at Team koco.com slash haha I
found an error we will sort it out right
here on the air let's see if you've got
what it takes to make chunk meat out of
the maestro